all right we're done we're hurting
hurting you know doesn't talk to me on
the street as we walk in while ago she
has to play pokemon go I said xpress Oh
like the thing that yeah give us a shot
of espresso words my pride no stay but
my fingers don't go bowling after
manicure lesson learned here's a child
don't tell the light choke sound Barisan
it's love I have a great story to tell
around this
good morning everybody happy we can
today I'm gonna do something a little
bit different with you guys I'm gonna
take you a little bit behind the scenes
of some of the fun that we have and
traveled and salsa TDs I sometimes talk
about it when that really behind the
scenes stuff of what we're doing so
today I'm according to us on a Saturday
we've got to first go and check out some
new flooring for TDs I pulled out some
options these are the two that I like
the best this one looks really good on
the floor they happen in the showroom
but its way lighter than I expected that
I wanted that I thought I would like and
this one is the safer bet so Alex and
Lily Alex you guys know Lily's another
instructor at tds are going to be coming
over we're going to drive to the place
which is about 30 minutes away or so
probably ate some breakfast have some
fun and talk and stuff and then we're
going to dance on the floor because they
have it on their actual floor that we're
gonna go there and test it out because
it has to be slippery enough today it's
officer but not to simply that you fall
over so this is Nina let me let me get
lower okay yeah but if I grew up here we
don't see you Nina I don't know if
anybody's ever gone there and dance on
the floor we're probably the first ones
with done it yeah but I'm curious we're
gonna try it how would you just love
look we're going to go for lunch nina
find this a place with our health versus
is a pain students who help out in some
of our classes and where we're going
burritos we're going through this i
don't want to go bowling and we do
something every month with our helpers
and volunteers and every quarter i pay
for it so this is the one that i pay for
so we're going burritos and bowling how
could you bully
you can pick up a bone yeah okay fine
from your technet it's five minute it's
amazing I have a feeling we're going to
get some amazing Nina bowling clips
today I'm very excited all right first
thing is we're going to meet lily and
Alex and go check out the floors this is
Lily behind me please one of our amazing
look what about in the wrong way one of
our amazing instructors at trata de
salsa she's holding up flooring she
brought her dating shoes I did I want my
Canadian tuxedo today yes this is this
is what I learned she I'm message here
to say I'm doing the vlogging do you
mind no it's good i brought my canadian
tuxedo apparently it's canadian tuxedo
is denim denim on denim these are them
intense yeah it's ball instead of Kate
Bostock scrutinize no I'm good with it
denim on denim is apparently Canadian
tuxedo cackling I don't know if I've
ever worn that I might have to it might
be the challenge okay we'll pick up alex
and Stefan is coming too let's go so the
girls went in to get tim hortons get us
some breakfast and I think meet my
sister and me Alex so I'm going to fill
up the car and I get the pump some gas
you don't look that happy this is
stephanie in the morning how we feeling
just have a coffee yet okay well alex is
chipper highway ice cap with my shut up
I said ence presso like the thing that
yeah give us a shot of espresso what
would your shirt oh no I have another
exactly of course we are here at King
wave flooring to get our floor alex is
Evan working on a snapchat we got Stacey
who's talking louder see this is the
floor this is it doesn't it look awesome
alex is really getting a closer person
with the floor broke down ours flat like
these little bumps here as people start
dancing the heels will always hit these
little Mark's here
it's not that supreme
yeah those are the two that's the safer
pick it matches more what we have like
this car I really like this floor but
it's kind of a risk it's a risk that
it's super differently not do well but
yeah literally wants to change your
floors now time to go get some food so
we are here at the burrito place it
brings back memories because there's
this huge lineup for people who want to
take a driving test I have a great story
to tell around this definitely used to
work for me way back talk from of those
good times it's like the best part of
her life mission to get as far away from
you anyway Africk that was it listen
this guy's one word is belong and all he
does is criticize a failed every driver
I failed my driver's is like three times
and then I had the rush to get to my
last test before my thing would expire
and I got on the highway instead of
driving that I thought was the right way
but ended up being the wrong way and I'm
going the speed limit here in Kenya is
100 mile hundred kilometers an hour and
over that translates into miles what
does that mean you know it's a hundred
kilometers an hour and i'm driving 120
to get there and then I realized wait a
minute I think we won the wrong way and
I called up stuck and record you have a
cell phone cell phones can be useful
sometimes I call up Stephanie in the
office a second can you look at this
address and she tells me that's in
mississauga and I'm going the exact
opposite way so I'm like massively late
have to turn around in the highway and
drive 140 they get to my driveway and I
just imagine me being pulled over by
police officers say I'm going way over
the speed limit and and I think I gotta
rush to my driver's test I'm going to be
late don't follow me over I actually
ended up being late for my test I missed
my appointment and I was unstained by
like these people standing back there I
was on standby there and I finally got
my appointment and I passed it so I
finally passed this is a good good
moments for me I didn't realize we're
coming
here but this is we're actually going
the grand opening a burrito Caliente
this is our is our menu option pick a
dish beef stink pulled pork shrimp
summer to battered fish fried eggs
marinated tofu Caliente goal County
salad and then we pick a tortilla choice
of toppings kind of sauce and then drink
time to order
you
enjoying our food I got it's like a
thing that leaf we think with a bunch of
stuff I mean I gather even spicy chicken
good one wats alex is talking about
people squads wats it's important as
long as I'm is waving and lily is on
snapchat now go check her out I likes
tell everybody like a pushup challenge
I'm doing the 20 to push our house which
raise awareness to my victims of PTSD
who veterans who commit suicide so the
statistic is that there are 22 suicides
every year in this case a platter ins
you to PTSD for the challenges for 22
days into the I can't we need a push-up
and part of the boys new challenges I
will call out every day directly to push
ups someone else so you make the
movement a little bit bigger it's for a
good cause and the only fed the veterans
affected families our society as a whole
and something to post traumatic stress
syndrome
oh the soda right see ya I Nina's doing
some Pokemon no I'm not you were there
was a Pokemon on Stephanie hey and you
did the pokemon on her let me show you
the pictures look at that this is pink
pokemon on Stephanie welcome to talk to
you in the street as we walk in while I
because you have to play pokemon go
alright walking out of the burrito place
I'm really fun are you doing who wants
to go to tim hortons yeah okay Timmy's
first people don't know you on the
YouTube channel who are you I am myself
Rosanna is an instructor to be and
instructed to be almost there she's most
just finishing her training never too
late to introduce yourself I am lily and
I'm a storyteller there you go tell us a
story oh I'm known for my jokes tell us
a joke that was so fun come on Alex it
was a joke right there yes I saw don't
tell the light joke no that's it forever
no one listened ok three guys standing
at the gates of heaven and st. Peter is
there juggling I mean going so the first
guy goes up in the sec okay i'm going to
give you a vehicle to travel on in
heaven based on how you treated your
wife so that first guy said i love my
wife we were married for 60 years and if
i could give up my life was the first a
second time for her I would he's like
okay here at Keystone pagadi second goes
up like I cheat on my wife once but we
went to therapy or married for 40 years
I loved her till the end so we you know
I died except okay here kids to a Ford
Focus this is third guy go that was like
I hated my wife I slept with her sister
and I only married her for money I
could've said her is that ok here is
scooter so darn scooter is right
heaven seeing all the majestic credible
things and he looks out into the field
and there's the guy with the Bugatti and
the gang of bacardi he's lying on a hood
of his car crying like IDK yes so the
guy goes up the goddess scooter drives
up some lemon he's like why are you
crying you're in a bacardi I can't pick
up any woman you and you're in heaven
what's wrong with you and the guy like
the guy so I just saw my wife and she
was on rollerblades here oh man how are
you good that's pretty good it's a
thinker rollerblades one and then you're
like oh she must have done so bad that
not only she can get a scooter Sheila
rollerblades Wow what could she have
done wow it's a thinker Nina takes every
change she came to play pokemon go yeah
she hides it but we know she's playing
let's go bowling so the women went to go
get socks we brought extra socks because
they don't want to put their bare feet
into the smelly bowling shoes Nina has
her socks she's ready to go with Pokemon
go I see it here we are viable
oh wow everybody finish your drinks Nina
is so obsessed with pokemon that she
wants she wants this pikachu go Alex
what's againi come on Alex here it is
what do you think there it is really
gets it what's it going for the Darth
Vader yeah and so oh my god this is
gonna be hard don't go don't go no no
pull with your good awesome oh oh oh no
you hit me right it isn't crap I know I
know them it's only one chance and
besides a bull bull bull
Lily's hiding behind Alex that's very
scary actually all right we're done
we're hurting hurting me miss back hurts
we're gonna start at the last round I
arm hurt my arm works Stephanie what
hurts is a minute here is God don't go
bowling after man in here lesson learned
what words my pride mostly but my
fingers fighting have done better
a little feeling defeated wow it's
beautiful to learn something new my name
put yourself out there optimistic for
the process it's beautiful to put
yourself out there and try something new
I like it thank you guys for watching
thank you for joining us on our exciting
exciting trip alex has long word is
belong let's integrity you guys to
believe or whatever your one word is
and I'll see you soup